this is not company though like thank
everybody who's sticking around to one
to witness this beautiful moment of a
person in a sense being reborn that when
a human being he comes to the
realization that it's a time in my life
that I have to ponder and thing was the
purpose of my life why am I here is it
just a play have fun go to the
nightclubs kick it on the weekends earn
some money have a good time and then I
die or is there more to life see people
dying every day it's very important that
we think about these things and this man
thought about it and he's been
researching for a few months now
contacted me we know each other a little
bit we've been talking he emailed me in
short
paraphrasing his email that he was once
a Christian but he always had this in
the back of his head the confusion of
the power that supposed to be given to
the Creator being given to somebody else
it didn't make sense so how does one
distinguish with all the different ways
of life calling to up to people telling
them that they're the only way how do we
distinguish what's the right way with
all this confusion when a human being
uses the tools that the creator of the
heavens and earth has given him he's
embedded in all of us this innate nature
to worship the One God a spiritual ship
in a sense so when you see the
attributes of man man is weak man is
born man dies when you see a cow you see
animals when you see the Sun these are
all the creations of the Creator but
when it comes to you the truth and the
attribute of the one who created you
that he's one and alone running this
universe that he doesn't become born he
doesn't die he doesn't eat and go to the
bathroom he's not a man that has an area
code a zip code now you consider
fingerprint him take his picture and the
girl he's cute that he has a color a
skin tone of skeleton that he eats host
to the bathroom comes out of the womb of
a woman this is not God and this is
something that anyone even if there are
non Muslim and they're listening the
inside of him if he's not bobbing his
head yes they
side of him is saying yes I want to
worship the One God the God who created
the Sun the Moon the God who Jesus
called upon when he fell on his face he
prayed to whom himself no he prayed to
the One God he prayed the same way Moses
prayed the same way Abraham prayed and
the same way we're praying here today
worshiping not the son of the moon on
Muhammad not Jesus were worshiping the
same way all the messages of god they
worship and when our new brother here
when he investigated this he took the
time out of his busy schedule he's an
architect he's a professional and he
trains the body and the mind and he says
man my soul I need to look into this a
little more because I spent all the
other time researching and studying how
to be the best architect how to make
money but this is a little more porn I
need to take a timeout so he picked up
the Quran which is the last and final
Testament the last and final revelation
it's not edited by man changed suited
for the time has been preserved for 1400
years if anyone wants to take a look it
challenges the reader prove if you find
one contradiction it can't be from God
God doesn't make mistakes so this book
that has been preserved that was
revealed over a span of 23 years in the
air bag the original he studied this he
looked into it he saw that the
attributes of the Creator that we
defined that he's one absolutely alone
worthy of worship not worshipping the
creation but worshiping the Creator he
acknowledges this in the same way that
this Shahada this testimony is nothing
new this is something that if you are
living during the time of Jesus as what
we have allegedly attributed to Jesus
because we know we don't have the past
books they've been changed we don't
have the originals but what we have
today we see Jesus peace be upon him
saying this is life eternal that they
may know you the only true God and Jesus
who you have sent so if you were living
during the time of Jesus you had to
follow him he was the way the truth and
the light he was a messenger teaching
you how to get close to God but he
didn't call you to worship Him none of
the messengers call on the people to
worship themselves Moses if you were
living during the time of Moses Moses
didn't call people to worship a man God
to worship the Sun the Moon he called
the people to worship the One God so did
Abraham they were ones who submitted
themselves to the one god this is the
same way of life that God has sent
throughout time it's a universal way of
life to surrender and to submit to the
One God doing what he wants you to do
not making your own organized religion
we should have to follow a man-made
religion and he has acknowledged that
he's going to be taking the declaration
of faith doing what all the messengers
of God did submitting to the one guy
Islam is not a new religion brought by
Muhammad is the same way of life that
was implemented during the time of Moses
Jesus Abraham Noah and all the messages
of God that came with that same way the
one way surrender is submit to God alone
and not his creation so we're going to
do the first step it's the Shahada are
you feeling good great alright so I'm
going to say it in English and then
we're going to do it in the air bit
now I just want to take a minute because
a lot of these things for new Muslims
for people when they hear certain Arabic
words some things you have to understand
is kind of foreign to them but when we
say hola we just defined who Allah is
he's not a man a monkey the Sun the moon
he's not like us can you be God you ask
yourself known because you have certain
man qualities God doesn't have the same
qualities he's the crate or where the
creation so when we say Allah he is one
absolute eternal he's not the father of
someone he doesn't have sons and
daughters like we do doesn't go to the
bathroom it gets sick and have to take
an advil no this is not God so this is a
law in Aramaic the language that Jesus
spoke he didn't speak English he didn't
say God he said Aloha in Hebrew at all
Elohim Allah doesn't take a person with
too much intelligence and too many
doctors degrees to see that hello Allah
Allah the same God that the Jews and
Christians who are Arabic speaking they
call on a lot so that's the testimony of
faith that he's taken our new brother
today is that he bears witness it's the
first negation of all the other guys to
be a money God can be your own mind
making God into something convenient in
your mind and you worship in your mind
instead of God the money the material
things a man a monkey an elephant
anything in the creation is
acknowledging that these are not God God
is the one who created everything in
this universe that's the one I'm going
to worship and prostrate to how can you
go wrong doing that so on English I
testify I bear witness that there is
none worthy of worship except the
creator of the heavens and earth Allah
and Mohammed
is His slave servant messenger
confirming Jesus Moses and all Abraham
and although the messengers do you
believe in yes I do were you co Hurst
that someone twist your arm and somebody
make you co Hirsch you put a spell on
you to do this nope beautiful now in the
Arabic all right Heather ashhadu an la
illaha illa Allah why shouldn't wash had
a feminine anna muhammadan Mohammad
Rasool Rasulullah before all the
brothers come and introduce themselves I
want to make this clear that this guy
that we worship is a merciful God he's a
loving God and when a person takes the
free choice of either worshiping the
creation of the crater he absorbs him
from all his sins clean his lake all his
bad deeds are turned into good piece of
yo somebody some money gotta pay the
debt he did something wrong to someone
you gotta go make a mess but God has
absorbed you of all your sins you're
like a newborn baby you're going to
establish the prayer five times a day
pay the charity fast during the month of
Ramadan do the Hajj when you're
physically and financially able stay
away from that invite people to good do
good and be the best human being that
you can be welcome to Islam my brother
there's only one word and helmet is his
messenger Allah that you like him Allah
Allah there's only one bad and Jesus was
his messenger Allah like I am Allah
Allah there's only one bad Moses was his
messenger Allah in love
way it's the right way it's the only way
feels good man it was really good its
best thing I ever did study study look
it up research it and may your mind
girlfriend except no it was pretty good
OSHA by show creator heavens of the
universe love love love love there's
only one guy he created Adam and we
you